WIL WILLIS: David,
Todd, congratulations.
Your work has advanced
you into this final round
of competition.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
blade from history.
That weapon is
the Cavalry Saber.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: The Cavalry
Saber emerged in Europe
around the 18th century.
With new developments
and battlefield tactics,
cavalry soldiers didn't
have time for fancy sword
plate or thrust.
The Cavalry Saber allowed
mounted soldiers to attack
with a deadly overhand slash.
It wasn't just the
curve of the weapon that
made it a dangerous chopper.
The tip of the blade was
thicker than the hilt
adding more power to the swing.
The sword has become one of the
more iconic weapons of its time
and was used by Captain
Jack Aubrey in the film
"Master and Commander."
Though lethal enough to cut
off an arm with a single swing,
the admin of gunpowder saw
the Cavalry Saber relegated
to ceremonial purposes.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
Yeah, let's do this.
[music playing]
TODD BITLER: I'm back at
my forge, happy to be home.
My design will actually
be off from the original.
The blade will have a
fair amount of curvature.
It'll be beautiful
and functional.
I used coal my whole life.
That's how I started out.
Everybody complains about coal.
Oh, it's hard.
Oh, I can't keep the fire hot.
They just don't know what to do.
[music playing]
Now, here's where
you gotta watch.
You don't want to overheat--
your metal.
I make my blades the old way.
I forge them by hand.
I use all hand tools.
It takes me a little
bit longer, but it
shows in the finished product.
It's not really cheap.
It's learning how to do
things and I'm a kind of guy
who wouldn't pay a penny to
see a pissing in a bale of hay
on a Sunday.
So I can fabricate
just about anything.
I can do custom cars,
bikes, rehab houses.
So they want the sword,
they're going to get a sword.
[music playing]
DAVID MOONEYHAM: And away we go.
We're here in Oklahoma
City in my home shop.
Behold the mess.
My shop is just very bare bones.
I've got hammers,
fire, and a grinder.
No turning back now.
My experience with
swords is mostly
fantasy blades like
katanas, the pirate cutlass,
that sort of thing.
So I've never tried to forge a
blade that large and never all
on one forging session.
Here's where that power hammer
would come in real handy.
Every heat, it's inducing a
little curve or a little twist.
It's such a long blade.
I correct one little
war for one little band.
There's another one beside.
It gets a little worse.
If I'm heating, I'm hammering.
I'm heating, I'm hammering,
and hammering, and hammering.
[music playing]
This thing is a
monster of a blade.
[music playing]
TODD BITLER: Day two,
and I'm feeling good.
I really want to make this blade
superb, so I pound the edge in.
Takes me a little bit longer,
but it's worth the time.
See that edge on that?
I'm basically right
down the sharp.
Best case scenario
is tomorrow, I
get this blade
quenched and start
on the guard and the handles.
And see what I've got?
Oh, and I see the burnout.
[bleep]
The thing with coal is
you cannot see the color.
When you're trying to
guess what the heat is,
just half a crank
can burn it up.
The blade is junk.
[bleep]
I'm kind of PO'd.
I just spent almost two
days making this blade.
But when the going gets
tough, the tough get going.
I'm going to start
another blade.
DAVID MOONEYHAM:
Finally, I'm done
with all the rough forging.
About ready to heat treat.
The sword is a beast.
It really is.
If this quench goes poorly
and I have to start over,
it really could
jeopardize my ability
to turn in the finished blade.
Hold on to your butts.
[music playing]
This baby is hard
like trigonometry.
Just look at it.
Spring!
I'm going to go ahead and
take some of these warps
out with a torch, and
move on to grinding.
[bleep]
Every bladesmith
knows this sound.
It's the dreaded
ping of death, and I
really don't like that sound.
I forgot that when
you dip it in water,
build a bunch of stress--
son of a bitch.
Caused it to crack.
Can't even explain how
disappointed I am right now.
Half the time is gone, and I
gotta start over completely.
TODD BITLER: Yesterday,
I made another blade.
So I'm going to really
move on this thing.
I got less than two days
to make this handle great.
The handle is going to be
made out of bird walnut.
It'll be filed in a spiral.
So your fingers feel
really comfortable.
I'm using my secret
magic potion.
Makes it look 200 years old.
Fine details really show up
in the end, so it's tedious.
It takes a lot of time.
But I think my skills show that
I'm ready for any challenge.
Yep, she's sharp.
Just keep on going.
DAVID MOONEYHAM: Last day,
and I'm quenching a new blade.
If I don't get this
right the first time,
I won't have enough
time to finish it.
Well, no tings.
Slap a handle on it.
Call it good.
I have no idea how to
finish this handle.
I think I'm just going
to go as fast as I can,
but this D-guard is
completely new to me.
I'm just going to have to
make it up as I go along.
Worst case scenario, I
just make something ugly.
Seriously no bueno here.
No, dammit.
Be a handle.
Not a piece of art, but it's
an instrument of destruction.
DAVID BAKER: The
Cavalry Saber was
a weapon that dominated
the battlefields of Europe
for almost 200 years.
So to test the sharpness
of your blades,
I'm going to take three
cuts against our bag here.
Now, Dave, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
DAVID BAKER: Going about
3/4 of the way through--
the curvature of your
weapon and the fact
that it is as sharp as it is
really did a nice job on that.
Interesting shaped guard, but
to quote a friend of mine,
this will cut.
All right, Todd, you're up.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
I'm ready.
[music playing]
DAVID BAKER: All right,
Todd, right off the bat,
we've got a bit of a
loose handle right there.
You can see that it
cut the bag nicely.
It is sharp, and it will cut.
So well done on that.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Place bits.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your saber can do,
I will take your sword and
deliver multiple strikes
on the ballistics dummy.
Dave, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Let's kill that dummy.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do it.
[music playing]
Dave, your blade is razor sharp.
On the initial
slash, you can see
how much it lacerated through.
Second one made it all
the way into the bone,
and even on the thrust, with
the way your blade is angled,
you can lacerate and gut
everything that's in there.
This, sir, will kill.
Good job.
- Awesome.
Thank you.
Todd, you're up next.
Are you ready?
Yep.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: OK, Todd.
On the horizontal slash with
the movement, it dug in nicely.
You've got a good configuration
with your blade here.
This weapon will kill.
Awesome.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
Thank you.
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen, to
test the edge of your blade,
we're going to take your
swords, clamp them in a vise,
and fire a ball at them.
Awesome.
DAVID BAKER: Dave, you're up.
DAVID MOONEYHAM: Tear it up.
DAVID BAKER: All right, guys.
3, 2, 1.
Fire!
[gunshot]
[music playing]
Yup.
Split it.
DAVID MOONEYHAM: I'm just super
relieved when I see those three
holes appear in the backdrop.
Dave, you can
actually see the two
points where the hollow
point bullet hit this blade.
Other than that small
deflection right
there, blade's held up nicely.
Sweet.
DAVID BAKER: All right,
Todd, are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
DAVID BAKER: All right,
gentlemen, in 3, 2, 1.
Fire!
[gunshot]
DAVID BAKER: Oh, yeah.
That's split.
[music playing]
So that bullet split
nicely on your sword.
There's a little bit of edge
deflection, but very little.
Still straight.
Hardly affected the edge at all.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
You've both done fantastic work.
However, in this
arena of competition,
there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
[music playing]
Dave, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Todd, please
surrender your weapon.
TODD BITLER: I'm very
proud of what I've done.
To make a blade, it doesn't
matter whether you've
made hundreds or one.
Things can happen at any
time, just like life.
I'm just going to move on and
do better, and continue to make
what I make, and do what I do.
[music playing]
WIL WILLIS: Dave,
congratulations,
you are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will receive a
check for $10,000.
Good job.
Thank you.
DAVID MOONEYHAM: I'm in
total shock over this.
I don't think any of this is
going to sink in until my feet
touch down in Oklahoma again.
I'm a hobbyist against a bunch
of full time bladesmiths.
I'm going to be talking
forever about this.
I'm very happy and excited.
[music playing]